I think I feel like Drake is more  Picasso and yay is more Matisse when we  talked about  and when me and Drake went to do the  show last year uh for a prison reform  and to bring awareness to the uh  incarceration of Larry Hoover I sent him  articles about the relationship of  Matisse and Picasso and the need for  these people you you need to have that  you know I need to go into the bar  and  go to Starbucks that's a you know that's  a form of a modern day bar right and  just hear Drake's song playing back to  back and Drake needs to go into that  same Starbucks just in a different city  and see people wearing Yeezys  and it puts us both back into the studio